M:Hoo!
M:Do you see that?
B:Ooo
B:Oooooo
M:Do you see that?!
B:Ooooooooooo
B:Yeah, I'm seeing this!
M:Haaaw!
M:Oh my god!
B:What?
M:What was that?
B:That was the most fucking epic thing
that's ever happened.
M:Yeah!
M:Just wait 'til a nutshot happens.
B:So we gotta investigate Abott some more.
M:Hey Abott!
B:This seems.
M:Abott!
B:Is this one way that we've
found before?
M:Abott?
B:Oh! It's upstairs.
B:Got it!
M:Gottee!
B:Don't worry.
B:I got it!
M:Cool!
M:You got it.
M:Ooh, and I can *stutter*.
I need to research this Officer.
M:Ok.
B:Sooooo
B:Let's go investigate Abott some more
B:Or whatever.
M:A'ight, cool man.
M:I'm down.
B:You know what I'm talking about right?
M:Aw fuck yeah dude!
M:I see an Abott over there man.
B:A
B:Wait where did you go?
M:*Mumbles*
B:I don't want to get too far away from you.
B:I like you.
M:Ay
M:Awww! You like me?
B:Hey
B:Yeeah
B:I got throught that whole
"You mean nothing to me" phase.
M:Aaaawww!
M:Thank you
B:You mean something to me now.
M:I
B:Or whatever.
B:Who cares?
M:Does that mean you're gonna shoot
me in the nuts?
M:Or
B:I mean maybe warm 'em up?
M:Uuuhh
B:Wow!
B:I fucking suck!
M:*Laughs*
B:A'ight!
M:Are you down there?
B:Peew!
M:Holy shit!
B:No I'm running around.
B:I got a double kill or we
got a double kill?
M:Ooouhhh!
B:I got a double kill or we
got a double kill?
B:I think we just got a double kill.
M:I
B:Aaaw shit snacks!
M:I was just looking at them and *stutter*
they exploded.
M:Either I have superpowers or this is about to
get interesting.
M:Ooh wait!
M:I can shoot this truck!
M:Kaboom!
M:Nice
M:Woooaah!
B:Oh God!
M:What is that?
B:*Unaudible*
B:There is stuff incoming in my position!
Run away from it!
M:Incoming?
B:For God's sake!
M:Uuuaaaaahh!!
B:Run faster!
M:I don't thinks It's... chasing...
B:Aah! Shit!
M:It's not chasing us! It's just
artillery, It's not *stutter* It's not smart!
B:I don't know where, oh.
M:It doesn't know what we're doing.
B:oh
B:I'm- I've only got two sniper shots left, I suck at this :(
M:You gotta grab ammo from people
you gotta hold E on their bodies
B:You gotta- you gotta search them?
M: You kind of gotta slap them on their ass
until you find some rifle ammo
Hmm
M:Yea
B:Well I'm going to go down here where we killed all these dudes and try to find some rifle ammo
M:I'LL COVER YOU FROM THE UPPERS >:D
B:I don't really thin thats how you say it but thanks
(Sad Markimoo) D-Dude it's the thought that counts man
c'mon :(
WHOAUAUAUAOA
OOOOOOOOOOOOOO SHIT SON
M:Guaaaaaaa
fuck, he's blind
B:I'm just going to search this corpse for a second
M:Hey, when I'm covering from the uppers-
M:Uh I might be in the middle of-
B:MOVE
M:*giggle*
(Scared Markimoo):AAAAAAHHHHHHH!!!!!!!
M:THE UPPERS HAVE BEEN COMPROMISED!                                                               B:*laughs*
B:Jesus fuck man
those artilleries, they really don't fuck around with that shit
M:Yeah
M:Good thing they give us a nice warning
M:I always appreciated that about World War II                                                                             B:IIIIIMMMMM COMING
B: Better look out!
'm comin'
(Mark trying to be cool) I'm comin
Ow
M:Ok, alright the uppers-
M:It didn't pan out up here
B:Oh shit
B:I'm low on health also
M:I thought I was fine also, probably until the *stutter* artillery blasted my ass
B:How long do you have until- your dead- of dying
M:Ahh like ten seconds I dunno
M:Take your time though, I'm good
B:I just don't have a lot of health so I'm going to heal for a second
M:O    K
B:Then I'll come get you, don't worry about it
B:It's probably fine
M:Well maybe not cause I think there's artillery incoming
B:Nah we're good
we're good
M:It looks like it's not good
B:We're gud
M:Pretty sure we ain't good
B:WE'RE GUD
M:I dunno
B:NO WE'RE FINE THIS IS FINE
EVERYTHING'S FINE
M:Ok
B:UHHHH
M:*stuttering*
Those are the COMFORTING explosions
B:You ok?
M:I'm ok
I healed
I'm good
B:You good on the- on the uppers up there?
M:Hell yeah, the uppers are secure
B:O god, I'm not good on the lowers
EHHHH
EHHH
(Mark in singing voice) AYYYYY
AYYYYYYY
M:I- I might die, I got nooooo ammo
B:I got two shots left                                                                                                 M:Shiiiiiiiiiiiiii
M:I'm going to charge in with my machine gun, and play this Call of Duty style
M: Fuck YOOOOOUUUUU
M:Fuck all of yooooouuuuuu
M:Ow ok, that didn't work out
B:Oh my god where the shit-
M:Hey apparently I play this like how I play Call of Duty
M:*casually* Yeah There's a tank
B:Ohhh good
M:Yeah sorry I forgot to warn you about that one
B:OOOOOOOKKKKKK
M:There's a nice-
B:I don't have any health packs and I only have one bar of health
M:Thats ok!
I'm just chillin' out here
it's fine
don't worry about me
I'm good
B:Oh good I picked up one bullet
that will be enough :|
B:Is this a stealth game oooorrrrrrr
M:Uhhh yeah know, who's to say?
M:They give you all these g-
M:WOW
B:Ok
B:Great
*Mark dying of laughter in the background*
B:Oh shit we get to start right here
ok cool
M:Ok I'm going to get off the uppers
the uppers ain't so up
M:You know what I mean?
B:The lowers weren't that much better but I was just more cautious than you
M:WHAAAAAAT
B:Oh wait we can go in there!
call convoy!
B:Wait we're missing an objective
M:What?
B:Lets just go the fucking side
B:Push tab man
B:In this building, that's where I'm going to be!
M:Convoy!
How you doing?
M:Oh weeeee wern't supposed to kill these guys
(Mark and Bob) OOOOOOHHHHHH
M:We're duuuumb
B:That makes sense why it was so hard then
M:Yeah
B:Oh they're up on the uppers! They're on the uppers!!!!
M:Are they? Do they see me?
Solider:Nothing else
B:No they still think we're up there I think
M:No I think they see me
B:Lets go, lets go this way over here
M:Alright, hang on, I gotta pat this guy's ass some more
B:They only have like five shots left
B:Oh fuck, they definitely see you
M:They see ME!?
B:Lets go this way
B:Yah they're shooting at you
M:Oh shit
M:Oh that oh- it wasn't OUR convoy
B:Oh god they're coming over here, they see me
M:Ohhhh
M:Shit
B:Ok good
B:Exellent
B:Not our convoy
B:Important fact
B:Oh for fucks sake
M:They grenaded me
B:Im fucking killing everyo-OH GOD JEESE
(Mark giggling in the background)
B:Alright well we caught the convoy at least, so that's cool
M:Yeah, to bad it was their convoy
B:Why do we call, why do we call their convoy?
M:Probably to like to trap 'em and kill 'em, I don't know
I'm going to do it again
B:I have like six bullets ok? How in the fuck am I killing an entire convoy
M:I've got seven
so you go up there
B:I actually only have two so this is really good all around
M:I'm going pick them of from a distaaance
B:Oh there was a bunch rifle ammo up here where you called the thing
(Confused Markimoo) WHAT
B:I got it now it's all mine
M:IS THERE ANY FOR ME!?
B:Uhh no
(sad Markimoo) ahhhhh
B:So are we trying to be sneaky dinky some more
M:Yah, ok you sneak ahead
M: And die...
M: And I'm gonna stay WAAAY away and shoot 'em from afar
M: How's that sound?
B: That sounds pretty much EXACTLY like what's about to happen
B: Like I don't wanna raise your expectations too high or anything, but...
B: I feel like (1) I'm really not understanding some fundamental concepts of this game
B: And (2) I suck
M: Okay, alright. I accept BOTH of those pieces of information AS fact!
M: HeeEY!! Look it's GUYS!
M: I'm gonna shoot 'em!
M: BANG! Oh.. nope...hang on.
M: Bang! Whoa..his teeth went away...
M: Dammit these guys are really hard to hit
M: WAIT! NO! WEAKNESS! AH! GODDAMM IT!
M: Convoy BITCH
M: Oh there's another one. I get a second try! BOOM!
M: That's what we're supposed to d- Oh shit...ow...
B: I'm bleeding out..oh god...
M: I'M COMING!
B: Just let me die...
B: ...Even though you can't win if I'm dead
M: Nonono I played a lot of Halo I know how to do this
M: Man these Germans...
M: They...they...they got somethin' going on here...
M: I dunno
B: They got strong FACES, man...
M: Yea..
B: Like, damn
M: I mean..maybe I got a strong face- I'm half-German, like...maybe...
B: You want me to shoot you in the face and see?
M: Yea, yea! C'mon man shoot me in the face!
B: What are you, chicken? C'mon bro!
M: No, no! Shoot me in the face!
B: I dare me to shoot you in the face!
M: Yea.
B: Don't stand up over there!
M: Hahaha
B: That's not where ya wanna be!
M: Okay I'm laying down, is this better??
B: OH GOD THERE'S A GUY IN MY ASS!
M: *laughing*
B: OH JEEZ I GOTTA GO OVER HERE
B: Oh for fuck's sake get to cover!
M: OW! Jesus...
B: Jesus Christ...
M: Where are they shooting from?
B: There's a FUCKING GUY OVER HERE!
M: Ooooooh-ha-ha-ha-oohhhh
B: GOD damn it haha
M: LAAARRRRY
B: *laughing*
M: C'mon now...
M: Fuckin' douchebag...WTF HOW I BLEEDING OUT?
B: Woahwoahwoah...OH THERE'S IFANTRY
B: Oh YOU GUN' DIE
B: YOU. GUN'. DIE. It's right on top of you..*laughing*
M: Nah nah it's cool man. I got a strong face, man. I got a STRONG face.